what do you think of this U.S General's
assessment that the British army is no
longer a top level fighting force do you
think it's accurate
I don't agree with them at all
um you know and you can find any
American General to give you one opinion
or another the fact is that the the
British Armed Forces might have been
weakened recently but they're still a
formidable fighting force and I think
our country can be proud of them
the the conversation that Deborah had
said that that um the defense Equity had
been told that the UK has been demoted
from tier one to tier two in terms of an
international fighting force
um I mean how does that work is that
some kind of formal structure or is this
just something that that's discussed
behind closed doors and and if this is
true how damaging is that I think it's a
subjective judgment by individual uh
commanders you know and they they vary
they come and go
um and although I've got my criticisms
of what the government is doing and how
it's conducting its defense at the
moment I would not agree with that and I
don't think the majority of people in
America would agree in the American
Military would agree with that
particular sentiment we still have a
formidable Force we're the second
military power in the west and we're a
nuclear weapon States so I don't think
any of our adversaries or enemies have
come to the same conclusion as this
particular American General has
and yet if you look at the details of
where we are financially the amount that
is being spent on our forces the
concerns about procurement of of new
weapons it would seem that perhaps the
British army is not as strong as perhaps
the government might like it to be
well it's not as strong as we would like
it to be and as the defense secretary
would like it to be but it's got to live
within the constraints of the
expenditure that it gets I believe that
there should be more money spent on
defense and that we should be
replenishing a lot of the stops that
we're giving at the present moment to
the ukrainians I think it's very
important that we don't just judge
defense based on spending and NATO I was
very clear that it was what we spent our
money on rather than the quantity of of
the money it's building capabilities and
we've got substantial capabilities but
they will erode and they will diminish
if the presence sort of cutbacks take
place and continue to take place if this
country wants to be properly defended in
a very a increasingly dangerous world
then it's going to have to make sure
that we have the right priority cities
in place so the Army the Navy and the
Air Force at our front line in defending
us against the threats that are out
there in the world today and they need
to get the resources that are required
where would you say the right priorities
would be then to spend these resources
we believe that this American General
has said some three billion pounds is
needed to be pumped into the defense
budget do you think that seems like the
right kind of sum
well three percent is fought prime
minister Liz trust was promising during
her very premium a very very brief prime
minister sure but it's probably quite
right and that shouldn't be gained
simply by the fact that our GNP goes
down it means focusing on capabilities
and on Readiness and making sure that
the defense of the country is based on a
realistic assessment of what is actually
needed that's why the defense review
that I did in 1998 was based on a
foreign policy Baseline I.E you know
what kind of what it is you want as a
country to do and then work out how you
how best you're going to do it and
that's what should be doing just now
that that Ben Wallace should be doing at
the moment and presenting the results of
that to the Prime Minister and I think
right across the board that would there
would need to be and must need to be a
strengthening of our capabilities
and that strengthening we know that
there are plans to shrink the Army
further in the future that are already
set out do you think it is time now to
Halt that it's too easy to Simply cut
back on the numbers uh in the uh in the
British army uh because of course so
much of the defense budget budget is
already committed and committed for the
long term and that's why uh Manpower and
woman power is being cut back as the
easiest option and I think we've got to
the stage now of stopping pretending
that reserves can make up the gap for
the number of people that we've actually
got the the actual physical boots on the
ground that would be required for the
future I don't think we should be
cutting back anymore
physically on the number of people in
there in the armed forces it's time to
properly look at what the country needs
and make sure that the resources are
available at the highest level for them
we have this refresher of defense policy
which is due on the 7th of March aside
from not cutting back army forces any
further what else would you like to see
in it well I would like to see some of
the uh the procurement uh projects
brought up to date and uh constrained
every year the National Audit office
does a survey of the procurement
projects which are usually Way Beyond
Target in both in times and in terms of
money and I think the country deserves
to make sure that the money that is
spent on defense is properly spent and
is spent wisely and in some areas I
think the the overspend means that uh
they're not getting proper value for
money nor are the troops and the people
who use them getting the equipment that
they require at the right time so that's
where I think uh uh there needs to be a
Searchlight put on our procurement
process
and in terms of procurement there are
some concerns that that something of a
black hole has been created by the level
of our support for Ukraine in terms of
the weapons that we now have in reserve
does that concern you or are you very
comfortable that what we have done for
Ukraine is is the right thing to do
regardless of the impact I think we have
to do much more for Ukraine and we have
to fill you know replenish the stocks
that we're using there as well but you
know the fact is that the enemy is at
the gate
you know our front line is no longer the
White Cliffs of Dover it's eastern
Ukraine
um they're fighting for us at the
present moment uh Putin has declared war
on the west and the front line of that
war isn't in the donbass and in eastern
Ukraine so this this little point in
keeping our Challenger tanks back on
Salisbury Plain when the front line is
actually out there in eastern Ukraine so
I think we've got to send more of our
equipment out there and then the Prime
Minister and the government as a whole
have got to make sure that they're
they're replenish those elements of
equipment that have been sent out
a final thought do you think Russia next
sees himself as a wartime prime minister
I don't know whether he sees himself as
a wartime prime minister but he is yeah
he's in he's in place at the present
moment and there is a threat to the
Safety and Security of people who live
in the west because of what Vladimir
Putin is doing so the prime minister is
the prime minister at the present moment
and he's got to rise to the occasion and
National Security is one of the
principal responsibilities of anybody
who occupies 10 Downing Street and
therefore he's got to be serious about
it serious about the resources that he
puts into it and frankly he's got to be
a lot more serious about taking on the
likes of Vladimir Putin at this time
because our safety is at risk